ça va être on va tester des des concepts
de son siège je sais ce qu'il a fait
c'est le plus grand simulateur de ce
type au monde le Technocentre Renault a
ouvert depuis le printemps dernier rads
un bâtiment de 2300 m² qui regroupe
plusieurs espaces de simulation roads
c'est un simulateur de
conduite ça veut dire que c'est un
système qui nous permet de tester les
voitures dans des conditions réel avant
que les voitures existent et qui vont
permettre de simuler le fonctionnement
de la voiture en condition réelle avec
un système
d'écran qui permet de projeter une scène
donc une configuration une route en
conditions réelles et vous allez tester
des comportements routiers ce concentré
de technologie permet de réduire les
coûts de 50 % tout en gagnant du temps
grâce à l'immersion Renault mobilise
moins de personnes sur le terrain pour
les tests l'entreprise produit moins de
prototype et développe des véhicules
fiables en série l'objectif c'est
d'abord d'améliorer
la vitesse de développement d'améliorer
la qualité des prestations qu'on va
donner à nos clients et également de
pouvoir tester en toute sécurité des
conditions je dirais extrêmes par
exemple vous pouvez simuler le même jour
des conditions avec une forte adhérence
quand il fait beau et une condition avec
de la neige sur la route et régler votre
comportement ou votre géométrie de train
par exemple 70 personnes travaillent
dans ce nouveau bâtiment des pièces sont
déjà testées sur ce site pour les
prochains véhic de la marque le premier
véhicule 100 % Road devrait être quant à
lui commercialisé en